DISGUSTING DETAILS AND THEIR
COMMENTS.
THEY BEGIN WITH THE D.C.
SWAMP WHERE A VERY ANGRY AND
VERY CONFUSED BEWILDERED
NANCY PELOSI CONTINUES
INEXPOLITIC CABBABLY TO
CLING ON TO HER B.S.
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
REPUBLICAN SENATORS COMING
UP.
FIRST, LET'S WATCH NANCY.
>> ARTICLES INDEFINITELY.
>> NO, I'M NOT HOLDING
INDEFINITELY.
I WILL SEND THEM OVER WHEN
I'M READY.
AND THAT WILL PROBABLY BE
SOON.
SAID IF I DON'T PASS THEM
OVER I WILL PASS THE U.S.,
MEXICO CANADA TRADE
AGREEMENT.
OKAY.
NO, WE WANT TO SEE WHAT THEY
ARE WILLING TO DO AND THE
MANNER WHICH HE THIS DO IT.
WE WILL NOT LET THEM SAY
IT'S LIKE CLINTON'S HEARING.
IT'S NOT.
DOCUMENTS, DOCUMENTATION,
WITNESSES FACTS, TRUTH.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE AFRAID
OF.
>> Sean: SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY PELOSI HAS BEEN SITTING
ON THE ARTICLES FOR OVER
THREE WEEKS.
THESE ARE THE VERY SAME
ARTICLES DEMOCRATS THEY WERE
CLAIMING THIS IS URGENT.
THE NATION IS AT RISK.
TIME SENSITIVE.
A MATTER OF IMMINENT
NATIONAL CONCERN.
PELOSI RAMMED THROUGH THE
HOUSE IN RECORD TIME.
ONLY ONE FACT WITNESS.
HEARSAY AND OPINION
WITNESSES.
DEMOCRATS, THEY DIDN'T
SUBPOENA ANY OF THE KEY
WITNESSES BECAUSE ACCORDING
TO THEM THE COUNTRY COULDN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT FOR A COURT
DECISION FOR WEEKS THEY HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NOTHING HAS
BEEN MORE URGENT THEY TOOK
IT RIGHT UP TO CHRISTMAS.
THEY WENT ON VACATION.
THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY
WAS AT STAKE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DO EXPECT THAT THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
PREPARED TO MOVE VERY
QUICKLY.
>> THE PRESIDENT, BEARED ON
HIS PAST PERFORMANCE WILL DO
EVERYTHING HE CAN TO MAKE IT
NOT A FAIR ELECTION.
THAT IS PART OF WHAT GIVES
US THE URGENCY TO PROCEED
WITH THIS IMPEACHMENT.
>> THE TIMING IS REALLY
DRIVEN BY THE URGENCY.
>>
YOU ARE
GENERAL THAT IS.
>> A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
>> YES A NATIONAL SECURITY
AN ISSUE OF OUR ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
>> IT'S NOT A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
IT'S A RUSH TO JUSTICE.
>> Sean: YEAH, WE HAVE GOT
TO GO ON VACATION AND TAKE
OUR TIME AND THEN WE WILL
SECOND GUESS.
OKAY.
PELOSI HAS NOW PAUSED THIS
SUPER IMPORTANT SUPER URGENT
PROCESS INDEFINITELY.
IT IS THE KIND OF LEVEL OF
HYPOCRISY OUTRIGHT
DISHONESTY AND LYING THAT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
BUT IT IS VERY FITTING.
DEMOCRATS, WITH THE HELP OF,
OF COURSE, THEIR BEST
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA MOB
STATE-RUN TV, THE DEEP
STATE, THEY HAVE BEEN LYING
TO YOU, TO US, EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
FIRST, WE HAVE THE
COMPROMISE, CORRUPT,
CONGENITAL LIAR, THE PENCIL
NECK I GUESS THE PRESIDENT
CALLS HIM, ADAM SCHIFF LYING
ABOUT THE TRANSCRIPT OF THE
CALL BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
NEXT SCHIFF LIED ABOUT THE
FAKE NON-WHISTLEBLOWER
WHISTLEBLOWER, REMEMBER HE
SAID HIS OFFICE THEY WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE CONTACT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
THEM.
THEY HAD NO CONTACT WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL.
WHEN, IN FACT, HIS OFFICE
WAS, IN FACT, COMMUNICATING
WITH THE HEARSAY
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER-
WHISTLEBLO
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER-WHISTLEBLO
WER EVEN BEFORE HE FILED THE
BOGUS COMPLAINT.
UP NEXT DEMOCRATS LIED ABOUT
WITNESS TESTIMONY DURING THE
SCHIFF SHOW, THE FIRST
AUDITION SHOW, THE SECRET
CLOSED DOOR WITNESS
REHEARSAL SHOW.
DEMOCRATS SELECTIVELY WERE
LEAKING ONLY THE MISLEADING
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO
IMPUGN THE PRESIDENT AND
GAIN PUBLIC FAVOR THAT'S
CALLED PROPAGANDA.
PASSED TWO BOGUS ARTICLES
WITH ONLY ONE FACT WITNESS.
THAT'S IT.
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND WHOSE
TESTIMONY WAS EXCULPATORY
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE WANTED NOTHING, NO QUID,
NO PRO, NO QUO LIKE JOE.
I WANT NOTHING PROCEEDING
DISHONEST TRAIN WRECK.
DECEIVED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND LIED TO GET THE SUPPORT
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THERE
WAS NEVER ANY I WANT.
NONEXISTENT.
THERE IS FOR QUID PRO QUO
JOE AND ZERO EXPERIENCED
HUNTER.
NOT GETTING THE BILLION
UNLESS YOU ARE FIRED.
THE PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING
MY ZERO SON.
NO BASIC FAIRNESS NO.
HIGH CRIMES, NO
MISDEMEANORS.
NO BRIBERY, NO TREASON.
ONE NEBULOUS ABUSE OF POWER
CHARGE.
WHATEVER THAT IS ONE TOTALLY
MADE UP OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS BECAUSE THIS
PRESIDENT DARED TO DO WHAT
ALL THE PRESIDENTS BEFORE
HIM HAVE DONE AND THAT IS
WHEN THEY CANNED GET ALONG
WITH THE EXECUTIVE AND
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH CAN YOU
SEEK REMEDY.
YOU CAN GO TO THE COURT
SYSTEM.
THEY SETTLE THOSE DISPUTES.
AFTER ALL, THEY WERE IN A
RUSH.
THIS WAS URGENT.
NOW PELOSI HAS ALL THE TIME
IN THE WORLD APPARENTLY.
GUESS AS NOT AS URGENT AS
SHE SAID ANOTHER LIE.
SHE IS DEMANDING MITCH
MCCONNELL FOLLOW HER STRICT
INSTRUCTIONS FOR HOW THE
SENATE TRIAL SHOULD BE RUN.
SHE WANTS HIM TO CALL ALL
THE WITNESSES THEY DIDN'T
CALL BUT, YET, THEY
INTREECHED
IMTREECHED
IMPEEECHED
IMPEACCHED
IMPEACHEED
IMPEACHEDD
IMPEACHED HIM.
THEY FAILED TO GET A
SUBPOENA.
SHE WANTS TO ENSURE A FAIR
TRIAL WITH TOTAL
IMPARTIALITY.
BIG PROBLEM THERE IS HER
BEST FRIEND HER BFF IN THE
SENATE CHUCK SCHUMER TOTALLY
AGREES.
BUT IN THE 1990s WHEN A
DEMOCRAT WAS BEING
IMPEACHED, CHUCK WAS RUNNING
ON EXONERATING CLINTON.
11 SEPARATE FELONIES KEN
STARR IDENTIFIED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS NOT A CRIMINAL
TRIAL.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE FOUNDING FATHERS DECIDED
TO PUT IN A BODY THAT WAS
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE WHIMS OF
POLITICS.
ALSO, IT'S ALSO NOT LIKE A
JURY BOX IN THE SENSE THAT
PEOPLE WILL CALL US AND
LOBBY US.
YOU DON'T HAVE JURORS CALL
AND LOBBY AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
IT'S QUITE DIFFERENT THAN A
JURY TRIAL TOTAL HYPOCRITE.
GET THE THEME HERE.
HYPOTHETICALS, LIARS, ZERO
PRINCIPLES, NO CORE VALUES,
SELECTIVE FAME MORAL
OUTRAGE.
CHUCKY SCHUMER RAN WITH THE
PROMISE TO ACQUIT PRESIDENT
CLINTON.
WITHOUT ANY CASE BEING
PRESENTED.
THE INDEPENDENT STARR REPORT
CLINTON COMMITTED HE
IDENTIFIED 11 SPECIFIC
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES
INCLUDING FELONIES.
CHUCK SCHUMER RAGED AGAINST
THE MERE PROSPECT OF EVER
IMPEACHING A U.S. PRESIDENT
OVER LYING AND SUBBOARDING
PERJURY AND PERJURY.
TAKE ACHE LOOK.
>> IF WE VOTE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT, I FEAR THAT
WE'LL BE SETTING A PRECEDENT
THAT WOULD COULD SERIOUSLY
WEAKEN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT IS
REMOVED FROM OFFICE OR NOT.
WE WILL BE IN DANGER OF ALL
TOO FREQUENTLY INVESTIGATING
PRESIDENTS AND SEEKING TO
REMOVE THEM FROM OFFICE NLTS
A MIRACLE OCCURS WE WILL
TAKE ONE OF THE MOST SERIOUS
AND RARE ACTIONS AND IMPEACH
PRESIDENT AGAINST THE
OVERWHELMING WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOW WE ARE ROUTINELY USING
CRIMINAL ACCUSATIONS AND
SCANDALS TO WIN THE
POLITICAL BATTLES IN
IDEOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES WE
CANNOT SETTLE AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
HISTORY WILL SHOW THAT WE
HAVE LOWERED THE BAR ON
IMPEACHMENT SO MUCH WE HAVE
BROKEN THE SEAL ON EXTREME
PENALTY SO CAVALIERLY THAT
IT WILL BE USED AS A ROUTINE
TOOL TO FIGHT POLITICAL
BATTLES.
MY FEAR IS THAT WHEN A
REPUBLICAN WINS THE WHITE
HOUSE, DEMOCRATS WILL DEMAND
PAY BACK.
>> THERE IS NO NEED TO
CONTINUE FORWARD BECAUSE
THERE ARE CERTAINLY NOT TOO
THIRDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT WE OUGHT TO BE DOING,
INSTEAD OF, THIS IS DOING
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT US TO DO.
>> Sean: CHUCKY'S OPINION,
OF COURSE, MAGICALLY EVOLVE.
SENATE GROWING PRETTY WEARY
OF THE SPECTACLE AND THE
OUTRAGE OF NANCY PELOSI,
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY AND HER
STALL TACTIC AND STUNT.
MAJORITY LEADER McCONNELL
CONSISTENTLY OFFERED THE
SAME RULES AND PROCEDURES
THAT THE SENATE APPROVED FOR
THE TRIAL OF BILL CLINTON
100 TO ZERO.
NOW TOP DEMOCRATS ARE ASKING
PELOSI END THE CHARADE.
THEY ARE DEMANDING IT.
EVEN SENATOR FINESTEIN
FELLOW CALIFORNIAN SAYING
IT'S PELOSI'S DECISION IF
THEY ARE SERIOUS AND URGENT,
SEND THEM OVER.
IF IT ISN'T, DON'T SEND IT
OVER.
DEMOCRAT DOUG JONES, AGNES
KING, JOE MARCH
KING, JOE MANCHIN, CHRIS
COONS, BLUMENTHAL ALL
ECHOING FINESTEIN'S YOU WILL
AT THIS MATE
UL THIS MATE
ULTIHIS MATE
ULTIMAS MATE
ULTIMATUMATE
ULTIMATUM.TE
ADAM SMITH RECANTS CALL FOR
PELOSI TO SEND IMPEACHMENT
TO SENATE.
LOOK AT THIS POLL WHOPPING
58% OF AMERICANS THINK
PELOSI NEEDS TO SEND THE
ARTICLES OVER.
DUE PROCESS AND FUNDAMENTAL
FAIRNESS.
DON'T EXPECT IT TONIGHT.
PELOSI STILL DESPERATELY
DRAGGING THIS ON AND ON AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HE IS TAKING
HER TO TASK.
PRETTY GAINING WAY AS
PRETTY EAINING WAY AS
PRETTY ENTNING WAY AS
PRETTY ENTERNG WAY AS
PRETTY ENTERTA WAY AS
PRETTY ENTERTAINAY AS
PRETTY ENTERTAININ AS
PRETTY ENTERTAININGAS
PRETTY ENTERTAINING WAY AS
WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BY THE WAY DID I NOTHING
WRONG.
THEY DON'T NOE WHAT THE HELL
IS GOING ON.
IN FACT, IT'S SO WEAK SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO PUT IN THE
ARTICLES IT'S SO WEAK.
THEY ARE SO PATHETIC THEY
ARE SO PATHETIC.
>> Sean: ACTION REVOLVED
AROUND THE PARTY'S DERANGED
PSYCHOSIS BESMIRCH HURT
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE DONE
FOR THREE YEARS.
NOTHING FOR ME WE YOU THE
PEOPLE.
ALL CONTINUOUS NONSTOP NEVER
ENDING POLITICAL STUNT,
LIES, COMMERCE CONSPIRACY,
SLANDER, BESMIRCHMENT,
NONBINDING UNMEANINGFUL WARS
ENFORCEMENT.
LET ME ADDRESS ALL OF YOU IN
THE U.S. SENATE TONIGHT ALL
OF YOU REPUBLICAN SENATORS,
YOU DO NOT AND SHOULD NOT
EVER LEND ANY CREDIBLE
EVER LEND CNY CREDIBLE
EVER LEND CRE CREDIBLE
EVER LEND CREDIREDIBLE
EVER LEND CREDIBIDIBLE
EVER LEND CREDIBILIBLE
EVER LEND CREDIBILITYE
EVER LEND CREDIBILITY TO
THIS DESPICABLE CORRUPT
SCHIFF SHOW.
DO NOT DO IT ALL YOU ARE
DOING IS HURTING AMERICA IN
THE PROCESS.
THE DEMOCRATS IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
YOUR JOB IS TO RUN THE
TRIAL, OF COURSE WITH THE
CHIEF JUSTICE PRESIDING.
LET THEM PRESENT THEIR CASE.
THEY IMPEACHED HIM.
LET THEM TELL YOU WHY.
NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR.
THEY CAN BRING IN THE ONE
FACT WITNESS.
CONSTITUTIONALLY, THEY
IMPEACH AND THEY PRESENT
THEIR CASE TO YOU.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE THE
EVIDENCE TO IMPEACH, YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE, YOU
REPUBLICAN SENATORS, IS THE
TRIAL THE CHIEF JUSTICE
PRESIDES.
ONE FACTS WITNESS BRING THEM
IN.
EVERYONE ELSE'S OPINION
FEDERAL RULES OF EVIDENCE
DON'T ALLOW HEARSAY EVIDENCE
TO BE PRESENTED.
MAKE THEM SHOW YOU WHY THEY
IMPEACHED DONALD J. TRUMP.
IT IS NOT YOUR JOB,
REPUBLICAN SENATORS OR YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE TO REDO
THEIR SICK, TWISTED CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION WITH NO DUE
PROCESS.
NOW, AFTER THE HOUSE
MANAGERS PRESENT THE
REASONS, THEIR CASE WHICH
WHY THEY IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
BRING IN THE ONE FACT
WITNESS THEY USE SO HE CAN
REPEAT AMBASSADOR SONDLAND
WHAT HE SAID OR READ BACK TO
THE HOUSE OR JUST READ BACK
THE TESTIMONY THEN YOU CAN
VOTE.
THAT'S YOUR JOB.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THEIR
JOB.
THEY IMPEACH AND THEN THEY
WILL TELL YOU WHY.
THEY ARE GOING TO PRESENT
THEIR CASE.
NOT YOUR JOB TO FIX THEIR
SCREW UP.
YOU REPUBLICAN SENATORS ARE
WEAK AND TIMID, IF YOU GIVE
CREDIBILITY TO THIS
REPULSIVE, CORRUPT POLITICAL
STUNT, YOU ARE AS GUILTY AS
SCHIFF, NADLER AND SPEAKER
IN NAME ONLY PELOSI.
THEY IMPEACHED, LET THEM
SHOW YOU WHY.
WHEN THEY FAIL
SPECTACULARLY, AND THEY
ALREADY HAVE.
AND THEY WILL.
THIS WILL END THE MADNESS.
IN OTHER WORDS, REPUBLICAN